Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 22nd,
2014 how's it going?
Really?
That's good.
Um,
that's it dude.
One more Monday.
There's one more Monday after this one.
Alright.
We're down to our second to last time out here
before I do this podcast,
right?
Oh man,
I got nothing to talk about this weekend.
No.
Why?
Cause old freckles is on fucking vacation.
All right.
I'm not doing shit.
I'm not doing it and I'm not through a fog.
You don't want to fuck with
bt good.
Bd is on vacation,
but I not good.
Okay
Bitch,
I'm gonna kill you.
MMM.
I have absolutely nothing to talk about because I've been in a fucking writer's
room and uh,
they had a lactic gig and I had been in the fucking bubble.
I have no idea what's going on in the world right now other than Sony leaks.
Everybody freaking out about Sony leaks.
Did you have to just read any?
No,
I didn't read any of the fucking things.
Why would I read that?
It's somebody else's email.
You fucking Weirdo.
Once you stand outside their window and rub your Dick,
you know
you're a piece of shit.
If you read any of those fucking emails,
that's all I'm saying.
Okay?
Because be honest with yourself.
If somebody stole your fucking all your Shit,
okay?
You wouldn't be in trouble.
You wouldn't be a little nervous.
You don't get a dick pic or a fucking or something.
Yeah,
you didn't look at something weird.
Okay?
All right?
You didn't trash the fucking chick one cubicle over cause you want to fuck her
and she won't.
So he starts saying she's a lesbian or she's frigid or some shit.
You probably said it way worse than that
right
now.
You're going to hold these people.
You're going to hold these people accountable,
these wonderful people over at Sony that make movies for your snot nose fucking
kids to watch.
So you can go on the other Roman fucking steal a fucking
okay,
20 minutes of sleep.
You know,
maybe go walk out onto your balcony and fucking hustle a little
smoke a little weed.
Why does that moment happened?
Because of people like Sony making movies about fucking stereotypical characters
on rugs flying around the Middle East,
right?
Talking planes and talk and cars.
Okay.
Fat People with no legs talking to computers,
all those fucking movies just because of people like them.
And what do you do?
You turn around,
you find out that they're fucking emails or on the Internet and what do you do?
You piece of shit.
How do you repay them for shutting your fucking snot nose kid up for two and a
half fucking two hours,
whatever.
Because of those wonderful people over at Sony,
you can take you a dumb ass kid that only you find cute.
Prop him up in front of the fucking TV and he can sit there at Goddamn
catatonic,
you know?
Well,
maybe you got time to go rub one out.
I'll go pour yourself a fucking whiskey.
Or maybe just have a couple of minutes to yourself and enjoy a piece of toast.
How do you repay them?
You immediately sit down in the fucking and your computer and you go and you
read the fucking emails
during the holiday season.
How dare you?
Yeah,
I could give a fuck about all of it.
Um,
I don't understand why they pulled the fucking movie though.
Yeah.
Do you really think the al Qaeda was going to do that shift?
Let's just say they were behind nine 11.
Who knows at this point,
right?
That's like,
you know who came up with the fucking grilled cheese sandwich at this point?
Everybody's claim responsibility.
I was my,
it was my aunt Harriet.
She lived in Wisconsin or some fucking bullshit.
Right?
Everybody's claimed fucking responsibility.
Everyone's been blamed for that.
From Saddam to al Qaeda to your buddy named Fred down the fucking street.
All right,
so let's just say that these guys,
you know,
these fucking 600 people on a jungle gym,
half a world away did this shit.
All right.
Let's just say they did it.
It telling me that they're going to go from knocking down buildings and a and a
and fucking blown up the Pentagon to attack in a movie theater.
Doesn't that seem like anticlimactic?
That's Kinda,
it's Kinda like as a comedian,
you would start with your best joke and then it just fucking tapers off from
there and then slowly you're just like the crowds just staring at you.
I mean,
I would think their next move would be something even bigger.
Right?
You think right?
If murdering innocent people is an art,
you'd want to progress like anybody else.
Does a guitar player want to be worse than he was the day before?
I don't think he does.
We got more movie theaters then they have members in al Qaeda.
I don't understand what the fucking problems.
What are they going to do?
They just gonna walk in.
They're going to get all those fucking cunts over here.
I guess they were just going to do it to one.
I don't know.
It just seemed like a pussy move.
We just caved.
We fucking caved.
Now what now?
What?
What's the next thing?
They're going to fucking threat.
Oh,
Jesus.
Am I doing that argument?
Yes.
We can't read newspapers.
I don't give a really,
I don't really give a shit about any fucking story in the news.
Uh,
unless it's some local guy did something heroic.
If it's somebody who saved a fucking animal or raw,
they're talking about what a piece of shit banks and insurance companies are.
Other than that,
I don't,
I don't care.
I don't like the environment.
I'm over the environment.
We're going to destroy it.
You know,
people are going to sit there and deny that we have any sort of effect on the
climate of this fucking planet.
Why now?
Why would we,
why would we do we,
we live on land and we've ruined the oceans.
How could we ever affect the climate?
There's over 1 trillion pieces of fucking plastic in the goddamn emotion.
We live on the land people.
How does that happen?
Is there a shark fucking up your backyard?
I don't think there is.
We're essentially the worst fucking thing on the planet and the coolest thing,
you know what I mean?
Cause we have an invention as far as I know,
no other animal on this planet has ever invented anything.
Not a fucking thing.
You know,
we get all excited.
You get all excited when you see your dog uses hands is like a pair of pause.
The whole the fucking bone.
Oh God.
Oh No.
Oh,
the bonus trade up and down.
Right.
We can make a robot dog at this point here that Cleo,
you're obsolete.
MMM.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I don't even know any,
anything that what the fuck is going on.
But you know something.
The next time somebody's account gets hacked,
why don't you have a little bit of empathy going like,
Hey,
you know,
I wouldn't like that to happen to me and just leave him the fuck alone.
Who gives a shit?
It's talking shit about different fucking people.
Of course they are.
This what people do.
That's what everybody does.
Okay.
Me An old Joe de Rosa.
We get on the phone.
Sometimes we'll call another fucking comedian and all three of us will just sit
there.
W first we start off,
we trash each other and then the circle just gets bigger and bigger.
Start trashing other people we know and sometimes what trash is somebody so,
well,
we actually call that person up because we don't want them to miss it.
Um,
anyways.
Who gives a fuck?
The Sony leaks acting like somebody broke into the fucking Pentagon.
Um,
anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
I'm fucking site.
I'm psyched.
The downstairs in my house is basically finished.
They get a couple of knickknack things at this point I'm over.
We actually moved in to the downstairs area.
Oh my God.
I was going to fucking,
I don't know what I was going to do.
I was going to take a bucket of water and dump it over.
My wife said other day,
right.
She wants to move the fucking bed downstairs.
Okay.
But the,
the workers still have to come here in the morning.
They got to do a little touch up paint.
They got fucking fixed days and that's a little off,
you know,
sand this thing down and she's all hot to trot to get the goddamn bed
downstairs.
All right.
And I get it.
I get it.
I understand.
When a man pays for a house,
it's not his house,
it's the woman's house.
It's a giant doll house and they're gonna fucking decorate it.
And they already knew what they were going to put in the fucking thing when they
were like seven years old.
Okay.
And I gave in to that shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
fine,
whatever.
You know,
go nuts.
Go nuts.
Because someday I'm going to Redo that fucking garage.
Okay.
I want to Redo that fucking garage.
I'm going to add a second floor to it and I'm going to only,
I will have keys to it.
And uh,
whenever I'm sick of you,
I'm just going to fucking go in there.
I'm sick of fucking dreaming about a house that has a garage that's separate
from the house.
I kind of have that in a way.
I'll just build a fucking upstairs and I will just say,
you are not allowed up there.
You know,
what do you think she's going to do?
Do you think she can actually leave it alone?
She bold.
She wants.
So anyways,
she wants to bring the bed downstairs.
Cle bed we have in the fucking house,
right.
We had a guest bed,
but it was out in the garage and the rain came down,
fucked up the mattress.
So we don't have,
while we have as a box spring upstairs,
what happened?
She gets to fucking people to put the goddamn bed there.
So we go downstairs.
All right.
Both of us had gone out the night before.
We were out until two two 30 in the fucking morning.
Now we're sleeping downstairs and who shows up at seven in the morning?
The fucking workers.
So now we got to get up.
We could've kept sleeping if we were upstairs.
So we get up,
we get up,
we walk upstairs and I'm not saying shit and we go upstairs and the only place
to sleep as the fucking couch.
And she goes and she just fucking lays down right in the goddamn couch and
immediately goes to sleep.
And I'm like,
what the fuck am I supposed to sleep?
She mumbled something and went back to sleep.
So I had to grab two cushions off the back of the couch,
walk in if fucking build like a mini bed on top of this fucking box spring.
And I went in there and I slept.
And uh,
was I in a fucking mood that day?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
But my wife is the shit.
While she's smarter,
she's smart as hell.
Cause afterwards when she asked me why I was being so snippy,
when I explained the scenario,
she apologized and it was sincere and she really meant it.
So then I was just left with this fucking anger.
I had nothing to do with right.
So I just went over my dog and I just put it in a headlock.
Right.
I just started fucking slum kid.
Um,
and it was this recent fucking advertising here for this week.
But my Christmas tree leap,
yeah,
went down there.
It's pretty good though.
The good people,
they didn't have a bunch of Charlie Brown Christmas trees.
Even though I like those ones,
I always feel bad for them or I just think they want them.
It's look better when there's less branches.
So to that fucking
shrub shaped like a ghost that most Christmas trees are actually bought a
Christmas tree that I'm taller than
just bought a little one.
You know,
my truck's still is storage because those workers still have this shit in the
garage.
Is this slowly fucking,
you know,
they're leaving my house the way we're leaving Afghanistan,
one tank at a time.
And um,
I dunno.
So,
and I usually just,
you know,
go on and get full size fucking tree and I just throw it in the back of my truck
and I drive down the street.
Like I'm a man and I know how to fix things,
you know.
But uh,
this year all I had was the Prius.
So what am I going to do is stick a giant fucking tree on there.
I'm not just give me a precise Christmas tree.
I could actually bullied my Christmas tree.
I could walk up to it and take all the ornaments in.
It wouldn't do anything,
could just stare at the fucking floor boards.
It's kind of sad.
And then I went,
this is our latest started got,
then I bought when I was eight called point sitios.
Those fucking red flowers bought them at the grocery store.
But the two last ones looking like a bought the,
they're all shriveled up looking like a junkie,
just sort of not enough or whatever.
And uh,
that's it.
Through some bulbs on it.
Put those fucking flowers on either side of the fireplace and it's over.
It's Christmas time.
So I do it.
I'm sorry guys.
I don't fucking have anything.
You know what I have,
I have some information for you.
Uh,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit everybody.
Slowly but surely this benefit is going to fuck it.
Sell out.
This is always a bitch.
Every God year,
you know,
hyping this thing around the holidays,
I'd love to get a tick is,
but I have to buy a scar from my aunt.
Um,
all right,
Patrice O'Neal benefit.
The third annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit is Wednesday,
February 11th,
2015 at 7:00 PM at this city center,
one 31 west,
55th street between sixth and Seventh Avenue.
Uh,
the lineup in alphabetical order.
Ben Bailey.
Bill Burke,
Colin Quinn,
David.
Tell Hannibal Burress,
Jim Florentine,
Jim Norton.
Michael Che Enrich Voss.
Yeah.
What the fuck else are you going to get a show like that tickets can be
purchased,
the falling away,
falling away online@wwwdotnyccitycenter.org or by calling (212) 581-1212 makes a
great fucking Christmas gift and a really helps us that do a wonderful thing for
the great Patrice O'Neil.
Um,
and whatever the box office window is.
One 31 west 55th street between sixth and Seventh Av.
And while I'm at it,
um,
if you guys are fans of the Rose Bowl and you live in the Lorraine,
is it Lorraine,
Ohio?
Lorraine Catholic was the name of the school that Jason Law had went to a rose
bowl lesson legend and grill master.
Yeah.
Jason Law head is going to be performing a theater.
This is a very unique show in Lorain,
Ohio and his hall of fame.
Uh,
high school basketball coach father is going to be opening up telling stories.
I don't think I've ever seen a father open up for a son at a standup show,
much less the hall of fame basketball coach who's going to be telling stories in
a couple of years ago.
And we did that bus tour through the south.
Uh,
he came along with us and it just really one of the most amazing human beings I
ever met.
Uh,
I think that's December 27th we'll have all that information if you want to go
once again,
that,
that also makes a great care Christmas gift.
Yeah.
Um,
so
I haven't been doing shit.
You know what I do?
You know what I do whenever the downtown comes around again as they fucking,
I get into cooking,
speaking at Jason Lawhead and last night for the first time ever,
I usually am a grill guy and pork chops.
I always broil them cause that's how I learned how to make them when I was a
kid.
You just broil them.
I'm just going to pause here and wait for all the food has to be like,
oh,
that you brew.
Um,
I actually pan seared.
Okay.
Pan seared is fucking pork chops last night and they were fucking delicious.
Brown them up on both sides and a skillet.
Right.
And then I took the skillet and I stuck it in the oven at 400 degrees
for like another five,
six minutes.
Probably should add him in there for seven.
They were pretty thick and uh,
took those fuckers out.
And I had this magazine,
the Tacho how to do,
uh,
it's called a butter bath.
I know,
I know.
I'm putting on weight here.
He just dropped some butter into the skillet afterwards.
You don't even have to have it on.
He did spend on the fucking oven,
so it's already hot,
right?
You just drop it in there and you throw in some sage brush sage time and ask
some rosemary,
couple of fucking little garlic,
a lot of knuckles whenever the fuck you call those things.
And he let that wants to bubble bubbles and the butterfly come up.
You just spoon it up and you drop it on the fucking porkchop forget it.
They'll fuck yourself.
Then you'd take the pork chop and Olivia cooked it for you.
Slap him in the face with you.
Say,
eat that shit and don't wipe the grease off your face around,
never cooked for you again.
I'll tell you,
they'll sit down and read that whole fucking thing with a smile on their face
and grease with rosemary in it right on the side of their face and they won't
feel humil humiliated at all as a true story.
That's what I did last night.
Um,
let's,
let me just read some fucking advertisement before this whole goddamn podcast
goes off the rails.
Okay?
Uh,
right there.
Um,
why don't we go here?
I actually don't have this at my fingertips anymore cause I had to fucking get a
new operating system.
And then like the notes thing where I write my,
uh,
ideas or whatever,
I have to sign up for some shit and they want all this fucking information.
Fucking Weirdos.
All right,
here we go.
Sherry's berries.
Everybody don't get your tensile in a tangle.
Is this Thursday?
Have you checked every one off your list?
Don't sweat it.
I can help avoid stressing out about what last minute gift to get.
Sherry's berries is a unique gift that is sure to be a hit and it's just a click
away with only if you're really stressing about a gift,
I don't think,
oh,
I know.
I'll get them chocolate strawberries.
This is the gift to give somebody that you got to get them a gift just to show
you making a fucking effort.
All right,
Sherry's berries.
Don't get,
don't get.
Don't get beside yourself.
All right.
Ah,
Shit.
I forgot to get my mother a gift.
I think we'll get a chocolate covered strawberries.
You'll fucking Disonia is a gift.
You get that broad,
you're banging,
but you're not going to commit to the relationship.
All right.
Was the only one day left to shop.
Your time is limited.
Give this incredible delicious gift and skip the crowds all together by Sherry's
berries and seconds.
Um,
we got freshly dipped strawberries from Sherry's berries starting in 1999 and
you can double those berries,
right?
For only $10 more.
Christmas isn't three days and we can still guarantee the delivery by Christmas.
You just need my code to take advantage of the deal,
bur bur are all right.
Additional copy points.
Describe the barriers in your own words.
Try using advertising adjectives like decadent,
fresh,
juicy,
sweet and irresistible.
All right,
I'll use all of them.
Sherry,
let me tell you something.
These deck in it.
Fresh,
juicy,
sweet chocolate covered strawberries.
They are irresistible.
Choose Barry's dipped in attempting white milk.
Dark chocolaty.
Goodness.
That's,
that's a kind of sentences.
Makes me hate fat people.
Is it really tempting?
Oh,
it's fucking strawberries on the corner,
man.
The fucking looking at me man.
Top Wall.
Right?
But we get the fucking point.
What am I doing it?
Visit [inaudible] dot com spell out the word Barry's,
B e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone on the top right hand corner and typing bur bur it's the
perfect gift without any hassle,
man.
This Christmas.
Yeah,
it is the perfect gift.
Who the fuck wants to go to a store?
You know,
I wanted to go buy some workout clothes to my wife.
So I went down to the Nike store and when I showed up the other day on a
Saturday,
right before Christmas,
there was a line of fucking people out the store.
And I'm thinking like,
oh,
this has to be those sneaker heads,
right?
This guy,
they're reissuing a fucking Patrick Ewings jock strap and all these guys,
all it's fucking dope.
I got to get it right.
So I figure I could just walk all around it.
But I was stopped at a red light and I looked at everybody in line and it was
all different aged people,
older people and Shit.
And I was like,
oh my God,
that's the line to get in the store.
Uh,
looks like somebody who's not getting workout clothes and now that wasn't going
to be the main gift.
That was just one of those things,
you know,
to fill out the area around the tree sweatpants.
A great takes up space.
The reason to Rep.
All right,
what do we got here?
Draft kings.com everybody,
the,
the list of millionaires crowned@draftkings.com this football season keeps on
growing and you know what?
You could be next.
Draft Kings is America's favorite one week fantasy football site where you can
win instant cash every God damn week.
And the beauty of one week fantasy is you can play whenever you want every week.
It's like a brand new season.
It takes watching football till a whole new level.
You're season long fantasy team might be missing the playoffs,
but the excitement begins again each and every week at draft kings.
Dad can't pick yet.
Take right there in minutes then enormous cash prizes could be yours.
True Story.
One player turned 10 bucks into five brand another turn two bucks into 10 grand.
Somebody else took 500 bucks in,
lost their rent money.
Draft kings.com I,
let's not act like everybody's a winner here.
This is still gambling.
That could take watching football to a next level and that level could be
beneath your floorboards.
Um,
another turn,
two bucks in the 10 grand a new millionaire has been made nearly every week this
season,
that draftkings.com you got to get on in on this.
All right,
but don't gamble more than you could afford to lose.
you dummy.
10 Bucks.
You can make 10 grand.
That's as far as you need to go.
Okay?
Don't turn into Fred Flintstone.
Bat that Bat,
Bat,
bat that I would have draft kings.com right now and use the Promo code defense,
the play for free and the $10 million fantasy football world championships,
draft kings.com bigger events,
bigger winners,
bigger millionaires.
Enter defense now@draftkings.com draftkings the icon that's draft kings.com
right there.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
You sick a dragon,
a rusty butter knife across your face because you can't afford the new blades.
Well,
we have a solution.
Draft Kings Duck,
a draft up shows,
dollar shave club.
Big shape.
Companies must think we're a bunch of scumbag criminals.
Whales do.
They lock up the raises in maximum security plastic.
Why do they do that?
You have to stand around like a convict waiting for the guard to come over and
unlock the raise a case.
What do they think?
He's some kind of jewel thief over there.
Next thing you know,
there'll be a security guard with a taser.
If you get too close to the razors,
you're not a criminal,
you're just some poor bastard or it needs a good shave.
Shouldn't get treated like one just because you want to pack a razors.
All right?
If you're sick of getting humiliated every week I got,
I got a solution.
Uh,
he don't even humiliate you.
Stick a white stand around linoleum.
Wait for that fucking rent a cop to come over and unlock a lock.
He could break with your two fingers,
right?
Just stick it in there like him,
the man of steel pieces of Shit,
little sliding glass.
The fuck is this.
Uh,
that's why I get my razors evidently@dollarshaveclub.com.
Their plan starts at just $3.
Their blades are amazing.
They arrive like clockwork.
He can shave with a fresh blade every week.
You see,
you're a moron if you don't do this,
if you're a young fella,
you know what I mean?
If you're not into the art shaving and you not going to go out and go buy a a
safety razor or a straight blade for fucking 200 bucks,
this is the way to go.
Dollar Shave club.com is the most convenient way to get a shave and it's the
least expensive too.
All right?
Over a million people get their razors from dollar shave club.com if you're part
of the club you're missing.
If you're not part of the club,
you're missing out.
Go to dollar shave club.com/burr now and check them out.
You won't be sorry.
That's dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] all right,
I like that guys.
I read those pretty good.
I think I read those pretty fucking good.
All right,
let's talk some fucking little bit of football this week.
Patriots,
jets.
Good.
Have you ever seen an uglier when?
Good Lord,
that was an ugly fucking game.
Um,
I actually think the judge should have won that game and my,
on my fucking mind and Gino Smith's should not be blamed for both of those sacs.
The second one and he said hike.
There was a guy in his face,
but that the first one that took him out of field goal range to the point the
guy had to kick it low and Vince Wilfork a fucking 350 pound guy,
somehow blocked a field goal.
Um,
I would blame him on that one,
but I'll tell you who I wouldn't blame.
I wouldn't blame Rex Ryan.
I,
uh,
as much as I think that guy,
has no class,
and then when he gets called on it,
he acts like a baby.
You know,
we talk talks,
all kinds of shit.
And then when they lose,
he's like,
you know,
people go to cruise sizes too,
but they have no right to,
yeah,
they do.
They don't get talked to a bunch of shit and said you were going to win the
whole thing and then you didn't,
you set yourself up for the criticism.
Um,
but I still think he's a fucking great coach and I don't think that that's the
problem with that team.
When he had the players,
he got him to the uh,
afe stay AAFC not the AFC East,
the fucking AFC championship game.
Jesus bill even watched the sport.
But um,
sometimes they just make a change because they feel like it quiets the fan base.
They just fucking lopped somebody's head off.
But I think that that would be a fucking mistake.
As much as I would love to see that guy.
I don't want to see him lose his job.
Like maybe lose the jet job and then go over to the NFC.
I don't fucking see that guy anymore.
He drives me up the fucking wall.
Like when Brady through that pick and then he's running on the field fucking
pumping his fists,
looking like some loser at the track cause it's dog finally came in,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
I just,
he had a,
I liked the guy,
but he just,
you know,
he talks all that shit.
And then when it's,
and then when he has a bad team,
he fucking clams up and acts like he learned a lesson.
Do you honestly think if rex Ryan gets another loaded team that he's not going
to start talking shit again.
Eaten Bundt cakes,
blowing out those stitches.
Um,
all right,
let me pull me plow ahead here and then I'm going to say my bill.
Burrs Superbowl pick standup comedian never played organized beyond the third
grades.
Bill Barr,
his Superbowl pick bump up,
boot up.
Suck my fucking Dick.
Um,
I'm taking Seattle Seahawks uptake.
I know that's not a bull pick,
but I gotta tell you something.
I've never been more wrong about a coach.
Then Pete Carroll,
I remember Pete Carroll was with the Patriots.
He followed bill Parcells.
He comes in,
he's a little pretty boys wearing dockers.
They make a good play.
He goes,
Woo.
I thought the guy was soft.
And then when he went to college and he want to chant,
you rebuilt the USC program.
They and what your dope got caught and ran out the back door when the wolves
started coming around.
I don't give a fuck.
You did what people do at Division One to win and the guy fucking one.
And I was like,
oh,
he's a college coach.
Don't probe coach.
Then he fucking goes to Seattle.
When a fuck with Sia were the fuck with the Seattle Seahawks
before Pete Carol?
Where were they?
Nowhere.
It's a bunch of star Brugge Starbucks drink and douchebags wearing Birkenstocks
and those rain ponchos just standing around in the rang.
They were all sad.
Seattle's go and know.
A lot of people don't realize is that's why Kurt Cobain killed himself.
It wasn't that the fucking all sir.
It wasn't the demons.
He was just sick of rooting for the mariners and the Seahawks.
So Pete Carroll goes in there with a fan base is literally suicidal and within
five years they get a fucking Superbowl.
That's hard enough to do,
but the hardest fucking thing to do,
I think as a Kevin never coached at any fucking level.
I think the hardest fucking thing to do is after you win a championship is to
come out the next year and get your team hungry again to do it again.
You know that Shit Pat Riley did.
Okay.
The Shit Bill Bellacheck did.
Like there's very few people that can motivate chuck Noll.
Did it twice to get them hungry again.
Fucking Seattle,
like dare fucking defense.
I,
I didn't know what to say about it.
Like I think if they somehow,
obviously if they get fucking home field event,
I just don't see anybody stopping and I certainly think that the,
the super bowl champion is going to be coming out of the NFC and I got a feeling
that the patriots,
we get home field.
All right.
We got a chance to go to the Superbowl again,
but we don't have,
I mean anything can happen.
All right.
This is me just speaking logically.
When I watched both teams,
I don't think that we have a shot against those guys.
Um,
but as a patriots fan,
I say fuck the Seahawks.
All right.
I,
I can't even say that.
I mean,
I don't know what the,
what,
what are we going to do?
What the fuck did we get?
You know,
we're doing well in the AFC.
I don't know why it always gets like this always gets really unbalanced.
Like fuck him in the beginning,
like the NFC when like the first,
I don't know how many fucking championships,
bowls,
and then the AFC went on this fucking run where we won like,
well,
Shit,
Bill,
you're a nerd.
You should know it went Steelers.
Steelers,
Raiders,
49 is one one,
one and 81 82 was the Redskins.
Okay.
83 was the Raiders and it was 49 years.
Oh,
it was the NFC that went on the run down.
It was and the bears.
That's right.
Then the NFC one on Iran.
AAFC was on a run and then NFC went on a run and I know one AFC now,
NFC again,
and I don't know why.
It always just gets like hell.
We seems like
like 60 or 70% of the NFL seasons either the AFC championship.
Oh,
the NFC championship game.
Everybody's going,
you know who's getting,
Whoa,
this is the fucking super bowl,
and then the Superbowl becomes a blow out.
All those fucking years.
It was a blowout.
The Broncos lost to the giants.
That was all right one.
Then they get smoked by the fucking red skins.
After going up 14 to nothing,
then 49 his Bengals was great and then Broncos got raped,
fucking raped.
Oh,
the pagers got raped by the bears before all that bullshit to ball 20 and a
fucking Broncos got raped 55 to something by the 49 or 10 a close game with the
bills giants,
one in the Redskins handled the bills and then the bills got raped twice in a
row by the fucking cowboys.
And was it 49 his charges,
Jesus Christ.
That was like a bad pay per view fight,
you know.
Um,
I don't want,
I'm talking about,
I just think the Seahawks or ah,
I think the too good and that fucking Wilson Kid,
that guy is the next guy.
I think he's the next guy.
Even beyond a MIP.
Androulla Andrew Luck in the AFC.
Even though he's having a fucking blast yesterday.
It wasn't his fault.
Jesus Christ,
one guy drops a pass and they all fucking do it.
That cowboys colts game reminded me of the Superbowl last year.
Yeah,
one bad play in the first series of downs and they never got it back.
It's just all went off the fucking rails.
Yeah.
Fucking punch it through.
That pass.
Looks like a Robert Parish foul shot.
Right?
The guy's hands and he looked like me out there.
All right,
what am I talking about here?
Let's um,
let's move on here.
Let's get to some questions for this week.
How far into the podcast are we?
32 fucking minutes.
Oj Simpson.
Uh,
okay.
You don't,
I'm going to go off the rails here and I'm going to read one from my other that
I find actually founded.
I thought we didn't have enough questions this week.
So occasionally I'll dip into my other fucking account here to see what we got.
Come on.
You old ass fucking computer.
So fucking slow here.
All right dear Billy,
because stanza,
uh,
recently or does that Jason Alexander fucking
okay.
Cause I'm bald and I yell.
Recently I was in Boston for work and decided to visit a good old friend of mine
from back in the day while I was visiting.
I happen to run into his younger sister who is my age.
Nothing creepy.
G in high school I was the bad boy.
Class clown.
Ah Gee.
What were you in Greece?
Fucking jerk off.
Just pictured.
You want a leather jacket?
I'll go is all the book up paper.
Um,
I loved all those thing and jerk offs.
Like the people thought that they fucking built that car.
They were in the glee club.
All right.
It's the burnout,
the burnout.
It's down the hall and fucking woodshop and the power mechanics.
They could do something like that anyways.
And she was the,
you know,
I've never seen Greece.
I've never seen it.
Whenever I turn it on,
they're always racing in the,
in the La River.
And I think one time I saw the ending,
but uh,
never seen it.
But I've seen all of Greece too.
And when I saw it,
I enjoyed it.
Um,
all right.
Plowing ahead of me.
In high school I was the bad boy.
Class clown,
man.
You know what I mean?
Man,
I was rebel.
Do you have a raccoon tailing and from the antenna your car?
They are fucking shifty.
And she was the Nerdy,
antisocial,
flat chested type.
I always knew she had a thing for me,
but I was too busy chasing all the,
who was over live.
Well bill,
it turns out she's become quite the young lady since then.
Master's degree,
great corporate Gig,
a great rack.
And then he writes a great rack and she happens to be single.
She insisted she show me.
It was so fucking funny as the way guys look at women,
I want to have women do that.
They just don't admit it.
And I'll turns out,
you know,
chairs,
you know he's got a straw job,
a great job.
Oh,
fucking fat pet movie of a big word.
What would you say?
Yeah,
a nice fucking literally sitting in fucking acting like I'm grabbing Dick and
balls right now.
Trying to think of the fucking word.
I don't know what the fuck they would say.
Do you guys ever do that?
Um,
anyways,
well it turns out she became quite the young lady,
blah,
Blah Blah.
And she happens to be single.
She insisted.
She show me around town all you know,
all the touristy shit.
So we exchanged numbers.
Donna,
later that day when I got back to my hotel,
we texting bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp now we no big deal.
Just catch up now.
Just catching up.
Okay.
Hi,
you're Ben.
How's the family?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Then we start talking on the phone.
All right,
and pretty soon get Dick's up.
I thought what she had for me in high school was ancient history,
but no,
the conversation soon took a turn and got romantic and he writes Joe g's.
So we made plans to meet for the next day for lunch the next day,
hanging out with my buddy.
I casually brought up if he would have a problem with me dating his sister,
he insisted he had no problem with it.
Ah,
you know what,
dude?
I thought you were a piece of shit.
There you go.
All right.
You're
such a weird thing.
I could never ask for freedom.
You might invite date your sister.
You mean what you mind if I,
if you're,
if you fuck my sister.
Yeah,
I do.
You better marry or you showed of a pitch.
So he's like,
okay,
great.
So I take her to lunch,
we do all the touristy stuff.
Then I took her back to her place while in the parking lot at her place.
She is getting out of my car and I go to give her a hug.
Good night.
This is when the hug turned into,
into a kiss.
Uh,
she got back in my car and we made out really hardcore bill.
I was surprised at how aggressive she was being all nerdy as she was.
Why do people think nerdy women don't have needs to,
you know,
they just a little introverted.
Well,
you got to do is give them the green light,
you know,
open the fucking door.
Um,
blah,
blah.
What the hell was it?
I was surprised at how aggressive she was.
She asked,
um,
I was surprised how aggressive she was being all nerdy she was,
but there was something oddly sexy about it.
Uh,
she asked to,
to ditch her place and go back to my hotel.
Oh fuck.
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
Jesus.
So I say,
okay,
cool.
On the way there.
I started having second thoughts.
I thought things might be moving too fast.
I know,
I know.
What a pussy.
No,
dude,
it's actually a benefit for you fucking
yeah,
to mature choice there.
If you've got other women that you just banging this,
this is not somebody you can just discard this.
Use your friends
sister.
He got to run into her again.
You got to go easy on this one.
It's a fucking ticking time bomb.
So anyways,
we got back to my room.
Nothing happened.
I cooled it off intentionally.
We had a few drinks,
talked,
joked around while she's laid on my bed.
This is what I noticed that she laughed exactly like my buddy,
her brother.
Oh No.
The more she laughed,
the more it's bothering me.
Needless to say,
that was the end of the night.
I'll make out session and a few drinks and some laughs.
So here's my question,
Bill.
I think this girl is perfect for me.
She's smart,
educated,
gorgeous girl.
But how can I get over that laugh?
All I could do was picture her brother and nothing kills the mood more than
that.
For me.
Am I being a dick for thinking about passing up this or is there something here?
Bill,
thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I don't know if there's something there you got to tell me,
but as far as I as an outsider looking in,
yeah,
you can't be with that girl.
You can end up fucking your friends
joking.
Um,
no,
I know what Jimmy,
I remember there was a buddy of mine
I had and his sister looked exactly like him with long hair.
I mean it was like,
it was uncanny how much they look like each other and you know,
she was a nice person.
Everything.
But it was,
it was my friend in drag
and you know,
so much of a relationship keeping it going is if he can make each other laugh
and if every time she fucking laughs
you got to break up with one on one of the two.
I don't know.
You break up with you.
You can't be friends with him anymore.
He's got to be with her long enough that,
that laugh.
It becomes her laugh.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Do you know what it really comes down to is how freaked out you are by it.
You know,
I mean,
every guy's had this,
you meet a girl in the bar and you're attracted to her and then she has the same
name as your mother.
It's like over,
over silver done deal.
Can't do it.
Can't tell you.
Get tell you.
See you later sweetheart.
Feel it.
You are trapped yet trampling on sacred ground.
This sweetheart,
get it.
What's your middle name?
Because I want to address you by your name.
When I say to get the fuck out of my face,
uh,
I dunno what you do there buddy.
I mean,
if you actually feel like this,
there's something there beyond the fact that you want to just banger,
which I don't think you have a problem finding a women to bag.
So maybe you do think of something about her.
I Dunno.
Uh,
that's going to be your Dell would have to be your choice.
Um,
just personally,
personally speaking,
I don't know if I met,
the girl did,
I thought was,
you know,
the one I'm supposed to be with.
Okay.
And she laughed like my best friend of,
Oh my God,
there's 7 billion people on the planet.
You can't find them.
Some woman to fuck that doesn't laugh like your friend.
Oh Geez.
You know,
I'm not good at advice today.
That even sounded ignorant to me.
Okay.
Could hear all the fucking women got so fucking stupid.
Um,
all right,
let's go back to this one.
Dear Billy,
because stands or recently I was in Boston for work and I decided to visit a
good of,
oh wait a minute.
What the fuck is this?
Oh,
wait a minute.
Okay.
Oh,
I copied and pasted it.
I'm a dummy.
All right.
Threats on your comedy,
Dear Bill.
If Jon il or the dictator of any country had a problem with your comedy and
strongly suggested or threatened you to never do a particular bit again,
would you stop doing that bit?
Um,
not in the United States.
I wouldn't,
not in Canada.
Not In an allied country.
But you know,
if I went over to Asia I would be,
I'd be a little lower.
I don't know if I would,
even if I was in China as far as I know,
they get along with Korea pretty well,
don't they?
So they're not really looking at any shifty Korean type of dude coming into
Thai.
I would be a little bit nervous.
I mean fucking that guy like feeds,
he fed his uncle till to wild dogs
that was like naked and just watched him fucking,
you know,
basically mall the guy to death and then eat them.
Yeah,
I would definitely be fucking nervous.
Um,
what I stopped doing the bit,
no,
I don't think I would stop doing the bit.
Uh,
but you know what,
these dates I have coming up going to like Singapore and Hong Kong and Shit like
that.
I would definitely be,
I would not do it in those countries.
You know
the fuck am I Chuck Norris was this Delta Force.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
But I mean if you're basically saying,
I dunno,
I dunno why they did that.
I guess I understand it on one level because God forbid,
what if some fucking copycat maniac actually went in and did something,
the amount of money that they would've got sued and who's getting who,
they don't make the money that they make if they used to make in movies anymore
because you guys all fucking steal them.
Um,
so I don't think that they could handle,
um,
putting out a fucking movie and then people get blown up or whatever gets shot
up or some shit and then they have to pay all the,
uh,
all the relatives.
So I guess I understand it but it's um,
yeah.
You know what's weird is if,
why do they make it public?
You know what I mean?
Like they shouldn't have made the wiki leaks or any of that shit.
Like they shouldn't even cover it on the news cause I would have never known.
Like if they leaked them out,
I never would know.
I never went,
I wouldn't have fucking night would had no idea.
One reason why I knew is because other people told me and I ended the fucker
news.
Just go about your business.
Who gives a fuck.
Okay.
So then the one,
they're making these stretch out.
We're going to do this once they make the threat,
I guess.
Yeah,
you can't back down or did that gives him power.
So I guess I'd have to do the bit,
unless I'm over on this side of the world and I'm,
you know,
I'm not saying shit.
Yeah.
You,
yeah.
Fucking get kidnapped.
Okay.
Have them do,
God knows what.
You know I what they do to the dolphins over there.
What the fuck are they going to do on me?
Um,
all right.
Christmas baking day,
Billy doughboy.
Uh,
what's happening in the bird kitchen this year?
Will you be baking?
One of your famous breads are Pi's.
Should we expect any pictures on Twitter of your creations?
I actually sent out a picture of the,
uh,
the pan seared,
um,
uh,
pork chops.
Technically,
if you bake a bread,
your house becomes a gingerbread house.
Hey,
no.
Oh,
JJ.
You know,
some of you guys are really funny and then other,
you guys,
right?
Like those jokes that used to see on the match game and everybody would fucking
laughed.
Like it was hilarious.
Charles Nelson Reilly,
um,
I gotta be honest with you.
Uh,
underrated.
Pan searing a piece of meat.
It's fucking incredible.
He pants here,
that fucker.
And then you bake baked bake it.
The worse the way through.
When the oven,
you take it out,
give it a little butter bath.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I got another,
a recipe for a,
uh,
had a pan sear a New York strip.
And if you ever told me that I was going to put a fucking New York Strip
and a God damn pants
in spirit,
I would say,
get the fuck away from me.
You're a communist.
I ain't what the fuck that means?
But whatever.
I would say get the fuck away from me.
But now after how unbelievable that pork chop tasted
juicy,
his God damn health.
Um,
I'm all about it.
Uh,
during the Christmas break here,
I'm going to up my,
uh,
pan searing game here.
Um,
you know what's awesome is I went down to the local butcher,
right?
We've got a great fucking butcher in our neighborhood.
And,
um,
I went over there and I put in the order for the fucking Rosebowl.
I'm so God damn site this year we're doing
yeah,
with doing some ribs.
We got the burgers.
La Head's going to make the fucking omelets.
You know,
it's funny,
I actually texted lol,
I had a picture of the,
uh,
the pan seared pork chops that I had and I said that,
I texted him cause he's like the fucking cook at the thing.
And I said just to let you know,
your backup is taken some snaps during practice.
Like I'm breathing down his fucking neck.
I can never be a better cook than that guy.
That guy is fucking unbelievable.
But um,
yeah,
I'm going to be making a pie this week.
Um,
I made some more pumpkin bread because it's a fucking joke to make now at this
point.
I love it.
Made it for two more people and I just,
I drive around La and I just dropping it off like a brick a weed and um,
yeah,
I like doing it.
In fact,
you know what?
I might make a fucking pie today just for the fuck of it.
Just cause I haven't made one.
I didn't make one over Thanksgiving because a fucking construction was going on.
I don't want to,
I don't want to forget how to make the fucking pie crust.
Now remember people who don't want to fully mix,
all right,
whatever you're shortening and everything with the flour you want to get.
It was just mixed where it's crumpled cause then you roll it out as your role in
the fucking thing out in the crust.
That's when the rest of the mixing happens.
If you already have it fully mixed and then you roll it out,
you're gonna to have a tough crust and that's one to grow on.
All right,
Christmas gift dilemma.
Hey Yo,
Billy [inaudible],
Billy boy.
Oh boy.
Oh wait,
let me do the rest of the fucking advertising here real quick.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
It's what we got to do.
A,
Hey,
if you want to donate to this podcast,
but not have to really give me any money,
uh,
next time you go to amazon.com,
just go to [inaudible] dot com first click on the podcast page.
Click on the APP,
the Amazon link,
whatever the fuck it's called,
little avatar there.
It takes you right to Amazon.
Everything's the exact same price.
And then they kicked me a little bit of money for driving some traffic over that
way.
No fucking skin off your fucking bulls.
The um,
all right,
eva [inaudible] everybody.
I love the flexibility that owning my own business provides.
Look at me.
I've created an empire with this show.
I love how they talk shift from he did Rex Ryan,
right?
This,
when it comes to handling,
handling business calls,
you're stuck with a challenge.
Either hire a full time receptionist that could potentially ruin your marriage
or handle all your calls yourself.
It's a lose lose.
That's why I love the voice.
They will set your business up with a toll free number or local number.
When customers call,
they're greeted by prospect,
greeted professionally.
Hello Sir.
By a virtual receptionists that will route all your route,
all your calls to wherever the hell you are.
There's even a dial by name directory.
You'll sound like a fortune 500 company,
and more importantly,
you'll never miss an important call all for under 13 bucks a month.
Right now for a limited time,
my listeners can try he voice for free for 60 days.
Seriously,
my list is getting candid,
an extended 60 day trial to test drive this amazing tool.
That's right.
60 days.
If you fucking deaf,
just for our listeners,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash build now to sign up,
set up your Eva's 60 x 60 day extended free trial.
Now he voiced.com/bill that's he voiced.com/.
Bill I love that there's even a dial by name directory.
That's funny.
If it's just you and your business,
then you just make up a bunch of other people's fucking names.
You know it's the hardest thing to do when you write a script is other than the
third act is coming up with fake names.
They always sound fake,
so you just start naming them people.
You went to high school with characters and that type of shit.
All right,
last thing here,
stamps.com everybody with the holidays almost here,
you don't have time to go to the post office and even if you go,
you have,
you don't,
you don't want to go.
If you do have time to go there,
there's going to be traffic.
There's going to be lines out the damn door,
you know supplies all over the floor.
It's an absolute shit show.
It's going to be packed with everyone mailing their holiday gifts,
a package.
She has packages.
You know what do what I do you stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can avoid
all the hassles,
man of going to the post office during the holiday season.
Everything you would do at the post office,
she could do right from your desk.
Why to help.
Would you go down there?
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer.
You can print postage for any letter or package the instant you need it.
Then the mailman picks it up.
It's a joke.
It's so easy and convenient.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters when I want to whore myself out and
make a little extra cash at the end of the show.
And you know what?
You should too.
You should use the damn thing right now.
Get this special offer when you use my last name.
Burn.
No risk trial.
Plus I had the high.
At what point is this not going to be a special offer?
It's been a special offer for three years,
$110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and $55 free postage.
Call for action verbatim.
I got to make sure I say every word here.
Don't wait.
Exclamation point.
Go to stamps.com comma,
before you do anything else,
comma,
click on the microphone at the top,
all capitals of the homepage and type in Burb,
B u r r that stamps.com comma,
enter burpee.
You are,
are
you said verbatim.
All right.
What a Douche.
I am.
Um,
I want to tell you about the lady I saw yelling at that person in the seven 11.
I don't what happened.
I walked in and this fucking lady was yelling at the seven 11 guy.
Right.
And I could tell by his energy he was right because he's just so,
that's just sort of smile.
Yeah.
All right,
lady.
Ah,
right.
All right.
And she's fucking flipping out.
You don't touch me.
You don't pull that out of my hand.
He's like,
hi.
And she's getting towards the door and she's cursing them out and everything and
he goes,
I have a nice night.
You have a nice night.
She just goes,
bullshit.
Bull Shit in your mouth.
Bullshit in your mouth.
You didn't mean that.
I never heard it said that way.
Bullshit in your mouth.
Um,
all right.
Christmas baking.
All right.
Did I answer that one yet?
Yeah,
I did.
Um,
Christmas.
You know what?
I want it.
I want to do a fucking prime rib,
prime rib dinner.
Popovers it some other fucking bullshit,
some sort of grains.
Fucking throw that down with a giant goblet,
a wine,
and just start snoring in the corner.
Like I fucking accomplished something.
And that'd be a great way to do it.
Hey,
you know what's,
you know what's fucking,
uh,
what are you doing cleo?
Huh?
Come here.
Can we have buddy be once in a while?
You've got to pet your dog even though you're doing something else.
Come here.
What's going on?
Huh?
What's up buddy?
Go for a hike later.
Fuck.
Oh,
underrated.
Scratching your dog on its neck under the collar.
Not a people.
Forget this spot.
It's so funny.
Shit ever.
The second you do it,
they extend their face and they have a look of satisfaction in their eyes.
You wish you could as a human being experienced,
whatever the fuck it is.
It their experience like
fucking dogs face right now.
He's like,
oh,
all right,
get out of here.
Alright,
you shitting machine?
You,
um,
oh,
when I was done with the pork chop last night,
I went out and rinse the thing off because my dog has a sensitive stomach.
If there's any spices on it,
she fucking gets to get still runs.
But uh,
rinse the whole,
fuck.
Hey,
get over there and laid out.
will you go
okay,
back over there and lay down
before we go on.
All the doors are closed.
Get over there and lay down.
MMM.
Rinsed off the bone.
It's actually my wife did it.
Why am I taking credits?
She's the one who did it.
I didn't have the balls to cause that's cause I take her for a walk and I have
to clean up the fucking shit show.
Literally.
She's like,
no,
I'll,
I'll wash it all off to the fucking joy
of a dog.
When you give it a fucking bone,
it's unbelievable.
Fucking throw it down.
They walk around it.
Tail Wagon.
They just can't fucking believe that this,
so God damn.
So I can get that gives the same can of dog food every goddamn night,
every morning.
And it will sit down,
but it's just eating the same shit just to get that fucking break.
Unbelievable.
All right.
Sorry.
Christmas gift dilemma.
Hey.
Oh Billy boy,
my fiancee.
And are big fans of your work.
Well thank you very much.
I am writing to ask you if you could tell him merry Christmas for me on your
podcast.
I don't have a lot of money to get them anything this year.
No.
Are you the fucking couple from the Bon Jovi Song?
John?
I used to work on the dog.
Yo,
what the fuck was Bon Jovi sitting in the box with?
Robert Kraft applauding a jets loss,
isn't he from New Jersey?
We got a holdout.
Do what we got.
I own arena football and it's not so great.
Maybe if I hang out with Bobby Craft,
I can buy the bills.
I'll give it a shot.
Sorry.
Um,
so you don't have a lot of money.
Okay.
I don't have any money,
uh,
to get them anything this year because I am working hard and trying to make a
living in theater.
He's incredibly supportive of my career and does everything he can to help me
and make me happy.
This year I had been trying to think of something I could do that was special
for him.
Uh,
this is where you come in.
I was wondering if you could take a few seconds on the podcast to say merry
fucking Christmas.
Yeah.
To drew from Marcy.
Oh,
to drew from Marcy.
I thought Marcy was the name of the town,
so fuck it.
Dope.
Marcy.
What?
Uh,
she loves you more than anything in the world and thinks everything.
Thanks you for everything you have done for her.
She can't wait.
All right,
so yeah,
wait a minute.
She loves you.
I thought this is from,
this is from a dude.
Merry Christmas to drew from Marcy.
I'm all fucking turned around here.
He is incredibly,
so much.
So you wrote,
he loves you.
She loves you.
Now he loves me,
right?
I'm just going to say,
well you said,
hey,
merry fucking Christmas.
Drope you can't help.
You have a 2015.
That's a,
I dunno,
twinkle toes.
I hope your books up.
Then a bunch of jobs and he become famous.
Say now you have your own podcast and everything works out for you and stick
with Marcy.
She seems like a wonderful woman.
There you go.
Did that warm?
You're fucking hot.
All right.
Flying a billet Bob.
First of all,
love the special and can't wait for F is for family.
Hey everybody.
Got To tell you guys what you guys have been doing.
Tweeting and Facebooking and talking about my special,
uh,
is,
is unbelievable the amount of new fans that I've gotten and all that type of
shit.
So I do not take that for granted.
Um,
thank you to everybody who's been doing that.
I really appreciate it.
Um,
that is all anyways,
um,
and I can't wait for F is for family.
You know what,
neither can I,
I did the last,
um,
records,
you know,
for the first six of them a Nia took this great picture too.
I should read.
I should tweet it out,
but um,
yeah,
I did a,
we just had a fucking blast.
It's the most fun fucking job I've ever had
and I,
I really think that this show is going a little rex Ryan.
Yeah.
I think if we fucking,
if we don't drop the ball,
this thing is going to be fucking hilarious.
Um,
yeah,
it's been,
uh,
it's been fucking ridiculous.
I fuck,
I got to wait a year.
It's fucking brutal.
Okay.
I wish it was coming up tomorrow.
Anyway.
Secondly,
congrats on the helicopter training.
I had a suspicion you were doing some kind of training or something because
every time I hear you talk about the atmosphere and Shit,
you've started sounding less and less like an idiot.
That was my favorite part of ground school was the weather.
Uh,
what is your favorite thing about flying?
And you need to cross over to the dark side and get your fixed wing certificate
for all you other people out there.
That's means to just fly in an airplane.
That's fixed.
Wing is in the wing is fixed as opposed to a helicopter.
We're just spinning around.
Okay.
And he goes,
I fly private jets and I'm a flight instructor out here in La.
Let's get you and your wife in something you guys can travel.
And Dude,
I love the fact that you think that I could ever afford something like that.
Those things are like fucking a zillion dollars.
Um,
now with your ADHD and your Dick's Dyslexia,
I'm sure you've botched reading this email.
So go fuck yourself.
Um,
that's a,
I don't know,
man.
I would
flying a jet.
That's got to be fucking unbelievable.
Um,
what do I like most about flying?
I'll tell you yesterday was the first day I actually felt like one with the
machine.
Like I actually,
you know,
it's kind of like when you have to stop thinking about driving and he could just
sort of feel the car,
you know,
you've just done it enough that you've just sort of fucking,
it's like you're sharing the same brain.
I finally,
I hadn't flown in a minute cause I was all busy and um,
but I was thinking about it a lot.
As crazy as that sounds.
I was thinking about different scenarios and then the inputs,
you know,
and uh,
okay.
I flew great.
I and my favorite,
you don't,
my favorite fucking part about flying a helicopter is a auto rotations.
Um,
and when I get my license,
I'm taking the advanced autorotation class.
We got to take it all the way down to the ground.
And for those of you people don't know,
that's like if you had an engine failure and like many people,
I also felt that if the engine failed on a helicopter,
you were fucked and you just fell out of the sky.
You don't,
it's actually safer I think anyways.
Then fixed wing because of the,
uh,
how,
okay.
Basically what the fixed wing,
you know,
you have to,
how fast you still have to be going when you land,
you know,
and if you're not on a fucking road and it's a God damn field in this tree
stumps there and shit,
that's why so many of those fucking fixed wing guys,
they get it on the fucking ground and they still die when they hit a fucking
tree because that thing is not designed to hit anything.
It's designed to fly.
It's all weight and balance.
So you're basically,
you're in a fucking golf cart and you fucking hit a tree.
It's 60 knots or whatever the fuck you gotta be flying.
I Dunno.
I don't know anything about fixing me.
How fast do you have to be going to still,
you know,
maintain lift or whatever.
But it's terrifying.
Whereas a helicopter,
um,
all right.
Really quickly,
and I'm going to sound like a moron.
I know.
So basically,
you know when you watch like a Rambo movie and they shoot out the,
the tail rotor and then the fucking helicopter starts spinning around.
Okay.
And then they fuck basically if you roll off the throttle,
okay.
The engine is no longer turning the main rotor,
which turning the main rotor is your,
your descent back down to the earth in the fucking air,
rushing up through the rotor,
the main road.
Okay.
You no longer need the tail rotor.
The tail rotor basically compensates for the fucking,
uh,
like if,
if your main rotor turns counter clockwise,
counterclockwise,
it wants to turn the ship clockwise.
So that's why you have the tail rotor on the back,
on site.
It's compensating for that torque so you can keep the fucking thing straight.
So you don't just spin around like a fucking top basically.
And if you see a helicopter that has two main rotors,
basically I guess it would be both like both giant rotors.
The reason why they don't need a tail rotors cause one turns clockwise.
The other one turns counter clockwise.
Both offsetting the torque and it keeps it fucking straight.
So basically if,
God forbid
you had an engine failure,
all you do is you roll off the throttle and the thing that I fly is you want to
be going about 65 knots and that's the speed you want to keep it at.
And as your rpms come up,
you catch him,
you pull up power,
which is the weirdest fucking thing.
Cause he think if he didn't want it to go up,
you push it down but you actually pull it up and you just fucking
just like that.
You fucking glide all the way down.
You pick it and you don't trim airspeed,
Rpm,
trim,
airspeed,
Rpm,
trim years doing that.
And then as the grounds coming out,
you know you're picking your spot is the ground comes up gentle aft cyclic.
You go into a flare,
you basically stopping the air,
push the cyclic forward and then you level okay.
And at that point,
and then you just drop 40 feet and you just drop to the ground and it right
about 10 feet off the deck,
you pull the power,
which is like pulling up the emergency brake and that last little bit of power
slows you down.
You drop like a fucking daisy.
Now I don't know how to do that yet.
I can do it all the way down to the flare.
And that's my favorite fucking thing to do.
And I've thought about that a zillion times on my couch.
Literally reenacting it and thinking it.
And believe it or not,
it actually helps you because I hadn't flown since November 5th and I went out
and we did some autos and I had two of the best ones I ever did.
I forgot to look at the RPM cause I was so psyched that I was in trim and that I
was at 65 knots and I was falling.
You know,
at though at the descending,
I should say at the right rate of speed.
And,
uh,
that's my favorite thing because it's all about what the fuck am I.
I just want to have those things so down that I can actually enjoy flying
around.
So I would say that that was the most,
most fun.
And another time I took out an our 44,
which is the four passenger,
and I flew up,
uh,
up the coast,
um,
right by lax out by the water.
And you got to be 150 feet off the ocean as you go through Bravo airspace and
you're looking at lax where you took off from a Zillion fucking times.
It's just a different view.
And then you come back up on the other side.
And I made a right at the fucking,
what the hell was it?
The,
uh,
the Ferris wheel there.
It's Santa Monica.
Then I flew right up,
but just followed Santa Monica like you driving down the road,
except you're in the air.
Went over all the houses in Beverly Hills.
Just kept going and going and going until I got out to fucking,
you know,
over where I live.
Flew over my fucking house,
little around some more out to the valley.
Then I flew over fucking dodger stadium.
So the next time I do that flight,
I'm going to fly over fucking dodger stadium and then over the rose bowl.
That's what I want to do.
And um,
I dunno,
I dunno about fixed wing.
I like fixed wing is fixed wing.
Seems like if you want to go,
if I wanted to start flying myself to my gigs,
which I don't,
cause I'm not gonna make any money,
the amount of money off to spend the fucking rent the plane in the jet fuel and
all of that fucking shit.
I don't want to do that.
But,
um,
what I like most about flying a helicopter is it's a,
it's truly like flying where you can just,
you can stop in the middle of the air,
like a fucking hummingbird.
And he'd go out over the ocean,
you see porpoises and shit that looks like a fucking giant shark and they need
to see a God Damn Bunch of people surfing.
And you sit there from that bird's eye view gone.
Yeah.
That right there is why I don't go in the fucking ocean.
Look at that thing.
What the fuck is that thing?
Swimming by itself.
Sharks are loners
anyways.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
I would say I could,
I could go on and on forever.
Um,
I would like eventually to a,
who's kidding,
who?
I'd like to have that fucking helicopter that the guy had a magnum Pi.
I would eventually love to have that.
In fact,
the next time I go to Hawaii,
there's a helicopter tour that they take you up in one of those 500 where the
fuck the thing is,
they got a painted just like that and they'll take you over the fucking
volcanoes and waterfalls and all that and I'm dying to do that shit.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
I thought I was too dumb to get through fucking ground school.
I still have to take the test and all that shit.
That's what it would be knocking out here before I go to Australia.
And um,
and then the second I get licensed,
I'm immediately going to take the advanced autorotation class where I have to
take it all the way to the flare and take it all the way down to the fucking
ground,
which they basically don't let you do cause they don't want you to beaten the
shit out of the helicopters.
Um,
maybe surprised with those skids can take,
especially with some of the fucking landings I've had,
I might as well talk about this shit.
One of the most fucked up things ever is the first time when they let you do
your solo,
just basically fly the traffic pattern around the airport.
You know,
I think if you're a sane person,
you never think you're ready to do that.
But they kind of know when you're ready and then they just have you set the
thing down and they go,
all right,
I'm stepping out,
fly the fucking pattern.
And you sit there and act like,
Hey,
I got this shit.
And then you fly it and you can't believe what you know.
Like the second time I did it,
a fucking jet blue plane was landing and I had to hold over this building,
this hangar.
They called me out my fucking tail number and told me to hold and I did it.
I was like a,
it was weird.
It was really weird.
Like,
Oh,
I actually know how to do that.
I mean,
I knew I knew how to do that,
but I didn't know how.
I knew.
I didn't know that I knew how to do that by myself.
And that's by the way,
what I call soloing flying by myself.
So anyways,
um,
what do I enjoy about it?
All of it.
I love that as much.
It's as much fun as playing drums and doing standup.
It's just another fun thing to do and yeah.
Okay.
If you got the fucking time to do it,
why wouldn't you go do it?
So I did.
It was,
uh,
something,
that kind of came about through freaking out about living in La and being in
conspiracy theory.
And then I did that bit about the,
um,
you know,
that guy commit suicide,
jumping out of the helicopter.
And,
uh,
I was already into helicopters,
but I,
I really,
it was one of those things in my head.
I just said that I,
I,
I couldn't do it.
Like,
I,
I couldn't give her get to ground school.
I couldn't,
I mean,
I actually really enjoyed it.
Um,
some of it,
some of that shit,
you know what the Shit I fucking hate.
I hate all that fucking
and all that fucking radio stuff and the fucking,
you know,
who do you contact if this happens and all that shit.
You basically need to know.
I find that stuff really teethies these,
but learning about weather and,
uh,
the markings,
all that shit around the airport was fucking interesting.
How the fucking thing flies actually the understand that now.
Um,
it's pretty,
uh,
it's pretty amazing.
And you guys remember me,
I mean,
a fucking year ago,
I didn't understand how a plane flew.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Do you think you can't do something?
Be fucking surprise.
So they got this kind of uplifting,
isn't it?
I hope it is.
Um,
anyways,
another year's gone by everybody.
Thank you for everyone who's come up to my show.
Anybody who was hyped,
anything that I'm doing.
Uh,
I got some shit for your fucking ass next year.
I'm telling you,
telling you.
I just made up pilot that I think of Mike go could be a funny fucking show.
I'm working on my new hour.
I got a sick ass fucking tour coming up at the south and I'm thinking of maybe
doing another red state tour and then hitting all the other ones.
I got to fucking,
I'm going to do some dates in Boston,
my hometown.
I haven't been there in a minute.
Good couple of years actually come in February.
I haven't been there in a couple of years,
so it's gotta be a big year for me next year.
And then of course I got F is for family coming out if the end of the Goddamn
year and it's kills me every week that I can't tell you anything more about it,
but I don't want to ruin it for you.
It's going to be a fucking monster,
I feel.
Who knows?
That's it.
Everybody have a merry Christmas,
happy Hanukkah,
Kwanzaa,
whatever the fuck it is you do.
God bless.
Shift.
I'll talk to you next Monday.
They'll fuck yourselves.